we begin with the tense situation in
ukraine after days of urging americans
living there to get out the state
department today ordered its
non-emergency employees to leave the u.s
embassy in kiev the capitol ahead of a
possible russian invasion in their
strongest directive to date the biden
administration the officials there are
warning that russia might attack in a
matter of days cbs news has learned that
russia has at its border stationed with
ukraine most of the forces it needs to
launch a full-scale invasion the u.s is
deploying additional forces to bolster
the american military presence in
eastern europe president biden is
expected to speak with russian president
vladimir putin by phone this morning
meanwhile a new cbs news yougov poll
reveals a majority 53 percent of
americans believe the u.s should stay
out of negotiations between russia and
ukraine christina raffini begins our
coverage at the white house this morning
christina good
good morning dana diplomatic sources
tell cbs news that embassy evacuation
started overnight but not all the staff
will be leaving the country some will be
going to a city called levive closer to
the polish border to provide limited
services for americans who might need
them but the white house is telling all
americans they have less than 24 to 48
hours to get out
if you stay
you are assuming
risk
with no guarantee that there will be any
other opportunity to leave
and there no prospect of a u.s military
evacuation national security advisor
jake sullivan repeated warnings that the
state department has issued for weeks
but the message for americans to leave
ukraine
came with a new sense of urgency we
obviously cannot predict the future
we don't know exactly what is going to
happen
but the risk is now high enough
and the threat is now immediate enough
that this is what prudence demands
u.s officials say russia now has 80
percent of the forces it will need to
launch a full-scale invasion and the
rest are on route
more than a hundred thousand russian
troops are amassed along ukraine's
borders to the east in russia and the
north in belarus
we're in a window
when an invasion could begin at any time
and to be clear that includes
during the olympics
friday the pentagon announced it's
sending three thousand more troops into
poland they will join the three thousand
others already there and in romania to
reinforce allies should putin decide to
make a move but the white house says the
american military is not going into
ukraine to fight russia or even to help
evacuations that's a world war when
americans and russia start shooting at
one another in an interview with nbc
president biden said russian president
vladimir putin knows not to put american
lives at risk i'm hoping
that if in fact he's foolish enough to
go in he's smart enough not to in fact
do anything that would negatively impact
non-american citizens
sources tell cbs about 7 000 americans
have registered with the embassy saying
that they're in the country but there
could be as many as 30 000 in ukraine
however many of them have family members
business interests or even homes they
may not want to leave jeff
christina thank you